hey would you sort of interest in you
because she thinks you're the chosen one
but I
Harry Potter is a classic film franchise
that's still adored to this day but even
the most successful franchises have a
few hilarious flubs we've compiled a
list of our favorite ones but Hagrid
there must be a mistake number one let's
talk quidditch there are a lot of things
to poke fun at when it comes to Harry
Potter and the Philosopher's Stone's
quidditch match but this one in
particular we can't help but point out
during the match we find out later that
Professor Coral is putting a curse on
Harry's broomstick causing him to flail
about when Harry nearly falls off his
broom he's obviously hanging on for dear
life while we end up noticing here are
the red wires that come out of a sweater
and attached to the broom just a bit of
movie Magic he's jinxing the broom
what have we done number two the most
famous line was actually improvised in
the chamber of secret scene Malfoy
approaches crab and Goyle who are
actually Harry and Ron in Disguise after
drinking a potion that allowed them to
change their appearance Harry is still
wearing his glasses so Malfoy asks why
are you wearing glasses this is where
the line comes in when Harry tells him
he was reading Tom Felton actually
forgot his line here and throughout this
one as a filler reading
I don't know you could read it ended up
working out smoothly as they ended up
keeping it in the film Bravo Tom
C Potter number three Emma Watson really
wanted to do a good job on her first
movie she was nine years old when she
landed the role of Hermione Granger and
she didn't want to screw it up so
intensely in fact that she not only
learned all of her lines but the lines
of her other castmates as well if you
closely watch the scene near the end
where Hermione Harry and Ron visit
Hagrid after exams you'll notice Emma
Watson mouthing Daniel Radcliffe's lines
wander around with dragon eggs in their
pocket why didn't I see it before
apparently she did it quite often
throughout the film and would even get
in trouble for it if all snipe wants the
Sorcerer's Stone widely try and kill you
during the Quidditch match number four a
funny little editing flub in Harry
Potter and the Goblet of Fire Harry is
faced with a dangerous task of rescuing
Ron from the great lake he ends up
heroically saving both Ron and another
young girl from Peril finishing second
to last the mistake that we noticed was
when Hermione approaches Harry and
places a third towel around his neck and
then right at the end when it pans out
the towel ends up back around Hermione's
neck it's giving magic number five maybe
Voldemort has a thing against hair Harry
this is Professor Quirrell he'll be your
defense against the dark Hearts teacher
so throughout the entirety of Harry
Potter and the Philosopher's Stone
Professor Coral sideburns are visible
just beneath his turban
this is something that can be easily
overlooked as we're not supposed to be
paying close attention to the professor
as he's flying under the radar as Lord
Voldemort's piggyback though in the end
when it's revealed that Voldemort is
hanging out on the back of his head he's
completely bald
yes you see what I've become number six
notably he could have gotten up but why
would he Gryffindor in the scene after
Harry gets sorted into Gryffindor he
takes his seat next to Ron soon after
when the feast begins it shows Harry
sitting between Hermione and Percy
perhaps these scenes were shot on two
different days and he simply forgot
where he was seated but either way it's
definitely a pretty funny continuity
error number seven we're pretty sure he
doesn't even go here scared Potter you
wish this chamber of secret scene is not
only important because it reveals Harry
as a parcel tongue but it's also
hilariously important because of the
major flub the fans caught on camera
right after Harry blasts Draco to the
ground with a spell you can see one of
the cameraman standing in the crowd of
kids not quite sure how they missed that
in post-production but I'm kind of glad
they did number eight more like the
cloak of green screen obviously to
achieve the cloak of invisibility's
effect on screen it makes sense that the
filmmakers would utilize a green screen
if you look closely at the scene where
Harry wakes up Ron in the middle of the
night there's something you've got to
say now come on check out the mirror of
erazed you can see the green fabric of
the invisibility cloak on the floor only
see us
looking properly go and stand there
number nine this one is easy to miss the
chosen outfits in this scene are not
only supposed to be fashionable but
functional in Harry Potter and the
Prisoner of Azkaban when Harry and
Hermione go back in time and are hiding
in Hagrid's Garden for a few moments
you're actually able to see the mic
packs that are discreetly hidden
underneath their jackets did you catch
that one on your first watch through
not really what my hair looks like from
the back number 10. did you know he has
his mother's eyes we're told time and
time again that he looks just like his
father except your eyes yeah my mother's
eyes though naturally fans have noticed
that not only do Daniel Radcliffe's eyes
not really resemble the actors used to
portray his late mother Lily but the
color is also different her eyes were
depicted as Brown and his are clearly
blue it's not necessarily the biggest
deal but considering how often it was
mentioned that he had his mother's eyes
you'd think they'd given the girl some
blue contacts
number 11. just a small outfit goof up
we're not going to get into the fact
that Snape's memories of Lily would mean
that he would have had to be present for
that
even though nowhere in the books or
movies doesn't mention his presence what
we're going to mention is the fact that
when Lily first gets hit with a curse
she's wearing a maroon sweater but when
Snape is holding her she's wearing a
blue shirt we guess Snape could be
misremembering but still
number 12. snakes are just fast at the
end of Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows part 2 of Voldemort snake nagini
attacks Harry Ron and Hermione from the
staircase but then soon after it cuts
back and a snake is now on flat ground
this actually happens quite a few times
throughout the scene where the snake is
in one spot and miraculously becomes
closer or even in a completely different
location it seems like no one really
knows where the snake was supposed to be
placed throughout this scene's entirety
number 13. we imagine broomsticks don't
usually come with metal seats stay in
formation everyone don't break ranks if
one of us is killed notably the flying
scenes were one of the most
uncomfortable scenes for the actress to
film they were usually always left with
sore bus to make the scene more
comfortable for them they were given
seats on top of the broomsticks that
were supposed to be cut out in post in
quite a few moments in Harry Potter and
the Philosopher's Stone you can see
Harry's seat as he flies through the air
number 14. let's talk about Dumbledore's
fall
before Professor Snape uses a famous
on Dumbledore causing him to fall off
the tower into his demise there is a
safety rail right behind him for some
reason though when Dumbledore actually
takes his fall the safety rail is gone
[Music]
number 15. what exactly is this spell
supposed to do everybody see me
can you all
hear me first introduced in the Chamber
of Secrets Expelliarmus is introduced as
a spell to disarm your opponent but it
rarely does just that
expelli honest
[Applause]
being Harry's favorite spell we've seen
it used countless times
even a few times where it actually does
disarm his opponent but the
inconsistencies of what the spell is
actually supposed to do are hard to
ignore what do you think is it meant to
disarm or meant to do actual harm how's
Theory supposed to prepare us for what's
out there so what do you think were you
able to catch these bloopers and little
mistakes when you first watch the films
what were some others that you think
should have been included let us know in
the comments and make sure to like And
subscribe to the things